joined by counsel to the president
Kellyanne Conway Kellyanne thanks so
much for being here tonight staying up
late for us and he Lara of course
absolutely any concern from the White
House about where this vote count stands
right at this moment we don't know about
flake Collins seems like a yes Murkowski
no clue we're feeling very confident
that everything the Democrats and even
dr. Ford have asked to be done in terms
of major accommodations over the last
two and a half weeks have been done the
FBI supplemental is completed and this
is the seventh count them seventh FBI
vetting that's been completed on judge
Cavanaugh including two just this
calendar year so now it's time to vote
and we feel pretty confident I'm not
going to get ahead of those who are
still sitting on the fence but I will
tell you Lara that there are some red
state Democrats who have a really
terrible a decision to make they either
have to accede to the will of their
voters who want judge Kavanagh confirmed
what that ninth seat filled in the
United States Supreme Court was just
started its new session or they can go
and be complicit with a process that has
been fraught with hysterics and
hyperbole and hyper partisanship and
hapless Democrats trying to undo
election results from two years ago
trying to slow down this nomination to
get ahead of the midterm elections this
year
and they have to decide where they're
gonna be part of that leftward drift
they own all those protesters if they
vote against judge cab and all they own
all the hysterics all the craziness that
you see there and I think that we're
going to have the votes and he ought to
be confirmed and by the way what's
happened in our culture Mary Matalin is
absolutely correct it won't go away once
judge Cavanaugh is on the Supreme Court
and integrity they're out there tomorrow
they're gonna be out there they're gonna
be caught they're gonna be protesting
it's our right to protest it's this
America your right to protest as long as
it's civil and the long as it shouldn't
get hurt but it hasn't been Richard
Blumenthal in Connecticut of course my
home state senator from Connecticut said
this today about this process Kellyanne
let's watch it strikes me as really a
neglect of the FBI's duty but the FBI is
not responsible I think
that the blame lies with the White House
that straitjacketed this investigation
you heard that Kellyanne throughout the
protests today that this this this
investigation was circumscribed
artificially the deadline was artificial
the real facts didn't get out this was a
rush job and frankly a con job that's
what the left and the protests are they
were saying well he's lying and of
course he has a history and not being
able to tell the truth he lied about his
service in Vietnam he didn't serve in
Vietnam he served during Vietnam and
that's not just a difference of a word
so this is somebody who sat stood right
behind
mazie Hirono of Hawaii last week when
she said I just want to tell the men of
America to shut up and he smirked and
then I guess he didn't understand what
she said because he's been talking since
that's one thing I agree with with her
he should definitely stop lying about
the FBI and this investigation and what
the White House did or didn't do the
people that dr. Ford herself claims
could have corroborated her allegations
were part of the FBI supplemental
investigation and guess what
ding-ding-ding they couldn't corroborate
her allegations it turns out you have
these fence sitting senators who have
very respectfully come forward Lauren
and said they think this was a thorough
investigation one of them said there's
not a hint of any misconduct and that
the allegations have not been
corroborated at the point is this
there's no nominee that President Trump
is going to put forward that's going to
satisfy liberal dick Blumenthal there's
no nominee that code pink would never
like this is about their yeah terms but
by the way speaking of the midterms I
want to thank all these crazy liberals
because they've done something that
wasn't able to do they've energized
disparate replan to keep it up though
try to keep it up got two more weeks
five more weeks there's no question
about it but I just want to tell these
folks of course they have a right to
protest and I lie the First Amendment
says you can act crazy also but 22.2
phrase we gotta go Kelly time's up and
time's up and move on and they all think
about that Kelly Anne thank you so much
for making time for us tonight